from an amnesty international
perspective I would say the biggest
dream that we would have for education
is to actually make the right to
educational reality for every single
child and adult in the world because
education is a fundamental human right
and it affects every single other right
and which is precisely why if you take
the economic social rights covenant the
right to education gets mentioned twice
and two different articles and whereas
for other economic social rights
governments have the option of
progressive realisation which means they
could do it over time for the right to
education they have been given only two
years to come up with a clear delivery
plan to make sure that compulsory and
free education is available to every
child in the world but the reality as we
know it is that there's more than 250
million children who are out of school
who are not really learning much and you
can be sure that these numbers are
severely underestimated now if you go to
the underlying reason why this is
happening
you'd find in most contexts that the
problem a fundamental underlying problem
is one of deep discrimination and that's
really a human rights issue whether it's
discrimination against girls against
minorities ethnic groups disabled people
so multiple forms of discrimination and
Prejudice so my dream is that we tackle
this discrimination in a very head-on
way honest international done various
studies you take children and
Afghanistan for example kids who are
displaced don't get access to education
a Palestinian Arab children in Israel
don't have access to education simply
because of their their antecedents but
it's not even just in poor countries and
some of the richest countries the Czech
Republic for example grow my children
are discriminated and don't have access
to education so yes my dream is that
every child doesn't suffer from
discrimination every adult who wants
lifelong learning is not excluded from
education every human being has a right
to education and this is
this is a fundamental right and the
world and the international community
and all of us need to work towards that
end there's no question in fact the
convention of the Rights of Child which
almost every government in the world has
signed up to it's clear that human
rights human dignity human values need
to be taught in schools and colleges I
think of the situation in Syria for
example today where we've had millions
of people who've lost their lives were
displaced lost their livelihoods would
this have happened if every individual
in Syria had a respect for fairness for
equality for the other so and if you
don't have this you might have education
but what we're saying in the world is
increasing numbers of educated
unemployed what are we going to have in
the world tomorrow if if every child and
every individual doesn't respect other
people for their intrinsic worth so yes
I think there's a lot of lip service
which is paid in fact the conventional
rights to child insist that this
included but in reality how many schools
and how many universities and colleges
deeply integrate human rights education
Amnesty International runs a global
program called Human Rights friendly
schools where it's fundamentally
integrated into the way in which the
school works it's not a matter of just
giving a lecture on human rights because
you know there's many lectures being
given on civic responsibility human
rights but it has to be internalized it
has to be converted into lived
experience and it's not in schools alone
but in every household but absolutely
the answers it must be integrated and it
must be done now
corruption affects every aspect of human
life it's very unfortunate but if you
think about why corruption affects
education and affects everything else
the fundamental problem in most
societies and this is particularly true
in emerging and developing countries but
it's not exclusively a problem of
developing countries but it's more
prevalent in poor countries and the
reason why that is the case is because
there is a complete lack of transparency
and accountability so if you want a
tacky corruption which is essential for
us to make sure that every child has
good quality education you have to
address the issue of transparency and
accountability without that there's
there is no way of tackling corruption
if you don't have a if you don't have
rule of law if you don't have Human
Rights if you don't have a system that
gives every individual equal access to
justice you're not going to have a
solution to corruption so and it is a
deep disease it cuts at the very
fundamentals and the roots of quality
education and quality Social Services
particularly for the poor and the
marginalized
so yes corruption as a endemic disease
but it can be tackled and it must be
tackled
so the private sector is obviously a
very key actor the way the world is
developed they're becoming much more
important than in the past in every
domain of human life including an
education and I was recently in Myanmar
and Burma and you can imagine that this
is now a new new economy a new country
which is just opening up new in the
sense that it's it's it's new to opening
up to the world and every single
corporation in the world wants to be in
Burma and Myanmar today and I'm using
this as an akan creat example of what
the private sector can do to respect
human rights and this is a good example
because the government there is very
weak
and you could easily have companies
particularly who are in the extractive
industry looking for mineral wealth
going into that country and extracting
the natural resources with little regard
for human rights but but the reality is
that you may be able to do that in the
short run but effectively what you're
going to do is to destroy the social
fabric of that country it's a deeply
divided fractured country and if you
don't respect human rights in that
country if the people who are living in
the areas where the mineral resources
are located don't feel that they're
getting a fair share of the wealth you
can be sure that there will be a
destabilized Burma or Myanmar in the
future so what what is what do we mean
by human rights compliant a private
sector approach it's very simple there's
no great rocket science about it what
Amnesty International would say is that
there is a set of you UN agreed human
rights standards which the bitchh
businesses across the world have agreed
to so what we'd expect every single
business to do is to ensure that there
is due diligence put in place but this
due diligence is put in place ex ante
not after the event but before the event
so before you have any investment going
and before you have any business
activity every business leader today has
to make sure that they do a check test
see to see what are the human rights
implications or consequences of their
investments of the operations so if you
can think through this logically to its
to its end conclusion you can be sure
that any
potential negative consequences are
taken care of just as you do with say
health and safety just as you do with
environmental damage will your actions
cause a human rights damage so at least
at a minimum it's a do no harm but
ideally businesses should be actually
promoting human rights promoting the
basic values that underlie human rights
and I think they have a huge road
cleaner